We hold people from Ukraine.
They're very beautiful, aren't they?
White skin, blue eyes, blonde hair.
We'll get there, don't worry.
And then I question,
so are we gonna home people now from Gaza?
Because I'm sure
if we hold everyone to an equal standard,
as a nation of sanctuary,
it is our time to show
what equity and Equality looks like.
You wonder why and how this is race related,
I'm sure without explanation. You see,
I don't like talking to people as if you're uneducated.
Cause if you were uneducated,
you wouldn't be here right now. Okay?
Everything that we see in the media,
even the BBC,
has now come out and said, oh,
they haven't provided this evidence though.
There was one gun in their video
and there's two guns in our video.
Like, come on.
Let me just put this out there to you guys.
I'm sure you've heard it before,
but let me give you an analogy.
I call them analogies. Cause my name is Nelly Adam,
aka Queen Niche.
And you know what, Israel?
I know who you are.
It's okay. We ain't nothing.
You don't scare us,
we don't disappear.
You kill our children,
you kill their parents,
you delete Palestine.